>>> SOME TELLING NEW NUMBERS OUT
OF TEXAS THIS MORNING WHERE
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT IS FIGHTING
TO LIMIT THE POWERS OF SCHOOLS
AND TOWNS TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
MASKS.
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT REPORTS
THAT MORE STUDENTS TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID-19 DURING ONE
WEEK THIS MONTH THAN DURING ANY
WEEK LAST SCHOOL YEAR.
FOUR DISTRICTS WITH THE MOST
CASES DO NOT HAVE ANY MASK
REQUIREMENTS.
CNN'S ROSA FLORES TALKED TO SOME
WORRIED PARENTS WHO WANT THAT TO
CHANGE.
>> Reporter: MICHELLE WOODARD
SENDS HER 8-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER
CARA TO SCHOOL IN HUMBLE, TEXAS,
IN A MASK AND SHIELD.
>> I'M SENDING HER TO A WAR
ZONE.
>> Reporter: THE DISTRICT
DOESN'T REQUIRE MASKS.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHAT KIND OF COMMUNITY BEHAVES
THIS WAY?
AND HOW CAN YOU CALL YOURSELF A
COMMUNITY WHEN YOU DON'T CARE
WHETHER OR NOT THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY LIVE OR DIE.
>> Reporter: NEARLY THREE WEEKS
INTO THE SCHOOL YEAR, HUMBLE ISD
REPORTS 1,500 STUDENTS AND 300
STAFF HAVE TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID, DESPITE THE GROWING
NUMBERS, PARENTS DROPPING OFF
THEIR CHILDREN AT SCHOOL NOT
WEARING MASKS.
>> IT'S A PERSONAL CHOICE.
IF YOU WANT TO DO IT, DO IT.
IF YOU FEEL SAFER DOING IT, DO
IT BY ALL MEANS.
>> EVERYBODY IN MY HOME, WE'RE
VACCINATED SO RIGHT NOW THE RISK
IS LOWER.
>> Reporter: THIS IS CARA HAVING
TROUBLE BREATHING IN FEBRUARY
2020.
>> IT WAS ONE OF THE WORST DAYS
OF MY LIFE.
>> SHE WAS HOSPITALIZED,
MICHELLE SAYS, MOST LIKELY FROM
COVID, AND WHILE SHE SHARED THE
VIDEO WITH SOME PARENTS, SHE
SAYS IT DIDN'T CONVINCE THEM TO
MASK THEIR CHILDREN.
>> THIS ISN'T A JOKE, THIS ISN'T
POLITICS.
THIS IS OUR KIDS' HEALTH.
>> RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOUR CHILD
HAS ASKED YOU ABOUT DEATH
REGARDING COVID?
>> Reporter: THESE MOMS WANT A
MASK MANDATE AT HUMBLE ISD.
>> I LOVE MY KID SO MUCH.
I'M GOING TO DO EVERY LAYER OF
PROTECTION THAT I CAN.
AND SAY THEIR PLEAS TO THE
DISTRICT HAVE FALLEN FLAT.
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE
MORE CHILDREN DYING FOR THEM TO
STEP UP AND DO SOMETHING.
AND THAT'S WHAT IS REALLY SCARY
AND REALLY FRUSTRATING.
>> Reporter: WE TOOK THEIR
CONCERNS TO THE DISTRICT.
>> WE ARE CONTINUING TO FOLLOW
THE GOVERNOR'S ORDER AND MASKS
WILL REMAIN OPTIONAL AT THIS
TIME.
>> Reporter: BUT YOU UNDERSTAND
WHY THEY HAVE THAT CONCERN
BECAUSE THE DISTRICT IS
FOLLOWING A POLITICIAN, VERSUS A
MEDICAL EXPERT AND ALL THE
MEDICAL EXPERTS SAY WEAR MASKS.
>> WE FOLLOWED THE GOVERNOR'S
ORDER LAST YEAR.
>> Reporter: IT MIGHT BE WHAT
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT WANTS BUT
IN HARRIS COUNTY, COUNTY JUDGE
LENA EDALGO SAYS CURRENT LAW IS
THE MASK MANDATE SHE ISSUED
WHICH HAS BEEN ALLOWED TO STAND
IN TEXAS COURTS.
>> THE MOST POWERFUL TOOL WE
HAVE IS PARENTS SPEAKING UP, IS
PARENTS RECOGNIZING THAT THE LAW
IS ON THEIR SIDE.
>> SHE'S BURNING UP, BUT SHE'S
TELLING ME SHE'S COLD.
>> Reporter: CARA STARTED
FEELING LAST WEEK AND TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID.
>> NOBODY IN THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITY CARES ABOUT WHETHER
SHE IS SAFE.
AND ALL OF THOSE THOUGHTS, LIKE
JUST KIND OF CULMINATED AND I
JUST LIKE, FELT THIS RAGE.
THIS WAS PREVENTABLE.
THIS DID NOT HAVE TO OCCUR.
>> Reporter: NOW CARA IS IN
QUARANTINE, A CHILD WHO DID HER
PART AND IS LEFT PAYING THE
CONSEQUENCES, HER MOTHER SAYS,
OF OTHER PEOPLE'S CHOICES.
ROSA FLORES, CNN, HOUSTON.
>> OUT OF THE KIDS HANDS.
WE WANT TO BRING IN CHIEF
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT SANJAY
GUPTA.
WE TALK ABOUT MASKS IN SCHOOLS,
AND THERE'S SOME NEW MODELING
OUT WHICH PROJECTS WHAT KIND OF
A DIFFERENCE IT CAN MAKE.
WHAT DOES IT SAY?
>> YEAH, SO THIS IS BASED ON
LOOKING AT LOTS OF DIFFERENT
STUDIES, OBSERVATIONAL STUDIES,
LARGE STUDIES LIKE THE ONE OUT
OF NORTH CAROLINA AND A MILLION
STUDENTS.
LET ME SHOW YOU, FIRST OF ALL,
IF YOU DO NOTHING AT ALL, JUST
LOOK AT HOW CONTAGIOUS THIS
VIRUS IS.
THEY SAY AT LEAST 75%, 75 TO 90%
OF CHILDREN, IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
ANY MITIGATION MEASURES IN PLACE
WILL BE EXPOSED TO THIS VIRUS.
IF YOU DO UNIVERSAL MASKING AND
IT'S UNIVERSAL MEANING THAT YOU
HAVE A MUCH LARGER IMPACT IF
EVERYONE IS DOING IT AS OPPOSED
TO SPORADICALLY DOING IT, 24 TO
50%.
IT'S NOT PERFECT.
YOU LAYER IN TESTING AS WELL,
THOUGH, 13 TO 22% EXPOSURE AS
COMPARED TO 75 TO 90%.
AND OTHER THINGS LIKE
VENTILATION, AND YOU CAN REALLY
START TO BRING DOWN TRANSMISSION
WITHIN SCHOOLS SIGNIFICANTLY.
YOU KNOW, ONE THING I JUST WANT
TO SAY AS A PARENT MYSELF, WE
TALK ABOUT THIS ALL THE TIME
THIS HAS OFTEN BEEN PRESENTED AS
A BENIGN DISEASE IN CHILDREN.
IT'S NOT.
I MEAN, MORE CHILDREN HAVE
ALREADY DIED OF THIS THAN HAVE
DIED IN SOME OF THE WORST FLU
SEASONS ON RECORD.
SO THREE TIMES AS MANY CHILDREN
HAVE DIED, THOUSANDS ARE IN THE
HOSPITAL RIGHT NOW, AND I HAVE
TO TELL YOU, WE STILL DON'T KNOW
THE LONG-TERM IMPACT OF THIS
VIRUS.
WE JUST DON'T.
YOU HEAR ABOUT KIDS TAKING COVID
NAPS FOR HOURS AND HOURS AFTER
BEING DIAGNOSED WITH COVID.
YOU DON'T WANT THIS, AND THERE
ARE WAYS TO PREVENT IT AS THESE
STATISTICS SHOW.
>> AND OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SUCH A
FRUSTRATING PARENT FOR PARENTS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
OPTION TO GET THEIR KIDS WHO ARE
YOUNG VACCINATED RIGHT NOW AS WE
ARE WAITING TO SEE WHAT
DETERMINATIONS THE FDA AND THE
CDC MAKES ON THAT, BUT SANJAY,
THERE'S ALSO A NEW CNN ANALYSIS
THAT LOOKED AT THE COST OF
TREATING COVID-19.
COMPARING WHAT IT COSTS TO BE
HOSPITALIZED TO JUST GETTING
VACCINATED AND WHAT DID THAT
ANALYSIS SHOW YOU?
>> THIS IS KIND OF MIND
BOGGLING, REALLY, TO THINK
ABOUT, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THESE NUMBERS, KEEP IN MIND,
THERE ARE STATES THAT ARE
OFFERING VISA GIFT CARDS FOR 150
BUCKS IF YOU SHOW UP AS WELL
JUST TO GET VACCINATED, BUT, YOU
KNOW, IT'S FREE, RIGHT, FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO GO GET THEIR
VACCINE.
WHAT DOES IT ACTUALLY COST?
WE DUG INTO THAT.
MEDICARE WILL REIMBURSE 150
BUCKS, 40 BUCKS PER SHOT,
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS, 35 MORE
DOLLARS IF THEY COME TO YOUR
HOME TO ADMINISTER IT.
ON AVERAGE, AND 98% THROUGH JUNE
AND JULY OF COVID PATIENTS WERE
UNVACCINATED, ON AVERAGE WHAT
DOES IT COST, ABOUT $22,000 FOR
THIS HOSPITALIZATION, 150 TIMES
AS MUCH AS WHAT MEDICARE
REIMBURSES FOR THE SHOT.
SOMEONE GOES ON A VENTILATOR, IT
CAN BE UP TO 300 TIMES THE COST
HERE.
SO, I MEAN, IN TERMS OF IF YOU
JUST LOOK AT THIS FROM A PURELY
FINANCIAL STANDPOINT, THERE IS
NO QUESTION IN ANYBODY'S MIND,
IT'S FREE, REALLY, YOU MIGHT GET
150 BUCKS BACK IN SOME STATES TO
GET THE SHOT COMPARED TO TENSE
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
HOSPITALIZATION.
>> I HAVE NEVER BEEN GOOD AT
MATH.
>> I WAS JUST GOING TO SAY THE
SAME THING.
>> BUT THE MATH HERE IS
EXTRAORDINARY.
>> IT'S OBVIOUS, YOU GET PAID IN
SOME INSTANCES TO GET
VACCINATED.
THAT'S WHY IT BLOWS MY MIND,
PEOPLE ARE PAYING FOR VACCINE
CARDS, YOU COULD GET ONE FOR
FREE AT YOUR LOCAL PHARMACY.
>> AND WE ALL PAY FOR THIS, WHEN
SOMEONE HAS MEDICAL BILLS THAT
ARE $22,000, IT DRIVES PREMIUMS
UP FOR EVERYBODY, AND THERE'S
ONE OTHER THING, YOU MIGHT DIE
IF YOU GET COVID, AND IF YOU GET
VACCINATED YOU ALMOST DEFINITELY
WON'T DIE FROM COVID.
ADD THAT TO THE DOLLARS AND
CENTS.
THAT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY NUMBER.
THE CDC VACCINE ADVISERS MET TO
DISCUSS BOOSTERS.
WHAT WAS LEARNED ABOUT WHERE
THINGS STAND?
>> LET ME SHOW YOU THE GRAPHS.
WE PULLED THIS FROM THE MEETING
HERE.
AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS, ONE
THING I'LL TELL YOU, THIS IS NOT
A SLAM DUNK DECISION WITHIN THE
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY.
THEY ARE VERY DIVIDED.
I HAVE SPENT THE WEEKEND TALKING
TO LOTS OF PEOPLE, BOOSTERS ARE
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY, OTHER
PEOPLE SAY SHOW ME THE DATA.
HERE'S SOME OF THE DATA, AND YOU
SEE, IT'S A LITTLE BIT HARD TO
READ BUT ON THE LEFT SIDE OF THE
SCREEN THERE YOU SEE THAT THERE
IS A WANING OF PROTECTION IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE ACTUALLY BEING
DIAGNOSED WITH COVID.
PRE-DELTA ON THE LEFT AND THEN
POST-DELTA, YOU SEE THAT DROP
OFF.
THAT COULD BE PEOPLE WHO JUST
COME BACK WITH A POSITIVE TEST.
IT COULD BE PEOPLE WHO HAVE SOME
SYMPTOMS, BUT LET ME SHOW YOU
THE NEXT SCREEN, AND I THINK
THIS IS WHAT REALLY SORT OF
GRABBED MY ATTENTION, GRABBED A
LOT OF PEOPLE'S ATTENTION IS
THAT IF YOU LOOK OVERALL AT
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS THE
TOP LINES THAT ARE FLAT ACROSS
THE TOP, THOSE ARE THE YOUNGEST
AGE GROUPS, THERE'S HARDLY ANY
DROP OFF IN TERMS OF EFFICACY,
IN TERMS OF EFFECTIVENESS, IF
YOU'RE 75 AND OLDER, YOU SEE
SOME DROP OFF THERE, THAT'S THE
LINE GOING DOWN TO THE RIGHT,
BUT TO ABOUT 80% VERSUS 95% IN
THE BEGINNING, SO THERE'S SOME
DROP OFF, AND IT MAY MAKE THE
CASE THAT BOOSTERS ARE
NECESSARY, BUT FOR CERTAIN
SEGMENTS OF THE POPULATION.
WE SAW THEM FOR IMMUNE
COMPROMISED ALREADY.
MAYBE IT'S FOR VULNERABLE PEOPLE
BASED ON AGE AS WELL.
WE'LL SEE.
THE CDC HAS GOT TO WEIGH IN ON
THIS, AND FORMALLY RECOMMEND IT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE TAKEN IT AS
PREORDAINED THAT BOOSTERS ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN, BUT AS WE CAN
TELL, IT'S NOT A SLAM DUNK,
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ON THIS.
>> SANJAY, I KNOW YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS CLOSELY.
DR. SANJAY GUPTA, WHO HAS A
MEDICAL DEGREE, HE'S GOOD AT
MATH.
>>